president Trump's former national
security advisor John Bolton is sounding
the alarm on his presidency while mr.
Trump appears to face new challenges in
his reelection campaign last night in a
startling interview I would even call it
jaw-dropping Bolton accused the
president of a pattern of illegal
behavior and threatening national
security this is ahead of the release of
his new book it's called the room where
it happened
which is being published by Simon &
Schuster that's a division of Viacom CBS
by the way is Ouija Jiang reports from
the White House Bolton is explaining why
he chose to launch his attack on the
president now we can get over one term
two terms I'm more troubled about John
Bolton claims he's speaking out now in
part to prevent president Trump from
winning another term I hope it will
remember him as a one-term president who
didn't plunge the country irretrievably
into a downward spiral we can't recall
from but lawmakers from both sides are
slamming the former National Security
Advisor who refused to participate in
the House impeachment case if John
Bolton had really wanted to get this
information out for reasons other than
his own personal profit he should have
come and testify before the House or the
Senate
Bolton said the President did link
military aid to investigations into his
political opponent the issue at the
heart of the impeachment inquiry in his
mind he was bargaining to get the
investigation using the resources of the
federal government which I found very
disturbing but he argues his testimony
would not have made a difference
Bolton is bringing attention to what he
says is the driving force behind mr.
Trump's decisions re-election a lot of
people have complained that he has a
short attention span and he doesn't
focus I want to say when it comes to
reelection his attention span was
infinite it's just too bad there wasn't
more that when it came to national
security
[Music]
over the weekend President Trump
relaunched his campaign in Tulsa and as
health officials warned about the
spreading virus the president said he
directed officials to slow down one of
the key tools to controlling it when you
do testing to that extent you're gonna
find more people you're gonna find more
cases so I said to my people slow the
testing down please
a White House official tells CBS News
mr. Trump was clearly speaking in jest
we've never had an empty seat and we
certainly won't in Oklahoma last week
President Trump in the campaign boasted
about the expected rally size insisting
that a million tickets had been
requested but on Saturday the president
looked out into a sea of blue empty
seats just over six thousand people
showed up sources familiar with the
Trump campaign tell CBS News that
President Trump was frustrated and angry
over the turnout in Oklahoma CBS News
has also learned there are concerns that
the campaign lacks an overall game plan
and many Republican sources noted the
President's speech on Saturday night did
not address his vision for a second term
Tony all right we hear that comment
about testing definitely stood out
because right now we turn to alarming
numbers in the corona virus pandemic